[Musique]
je vais vous donner le gel pour les
infectés se désinfecter les mains un
premier geste barrières pour les parents
qui se rendent au sein des centres de
protection maternelle et infantile la
prise de température ainsi que le
respect de la distanciation physique
font également partie de ces mesures
d'hygiène et de sécurité mises en place
par la collectivité au sein de ces
structures d'accueil au niveau de la
salle d'actes d'attentes les chaises
sont séparées il y à un marquage au sol
bien délimiter les espaces le personnel
d'accueil dispose d'une protection de
plexiglas quand ils accueillent la
personne pour les entretiens ou pour
uniquement des renseignements
chaque agent est doté d'un masque le gel
hydro alcoolique est proposée à l'entrée
pour les personnes qui arrivent se
désinfecter les mains et bien sûr le
lavage des mains avec de l'eau et du
savon et aussi préconisent les
consultations au sein des pmi se font
désormais uniquement sur rendez vous
afin de limiter les contacts physiques
les centres de protection maternelle et
infantile ont assuré des permanences
durant le confinement 25 pmi sont
opérationnelles et une réouverture
totale des centres est prévue pour le 2
juin prochain
[Musique]